but are you actually read CinemaCon let
me actually go I was gonna ask if you're
gonna sing today are you singing today
do they ask you I didn't know I like to
sing but I mean I don't want to get
bored of it sure wait to see the movie
what are you excited for people to see I
think I'm very excited is that you're
not telling like the pg-13 version no
you made an r-rated movie yeah so talk a
little bit about how this is different
than the other musical
instead of coming out recently the story
of a man at the story I goes to rehab
because he's not well it's hard to tell
that story in a really family friendly
way watch out for that guy to insist on
gently dark it's a grown-up story I
believe a very celebratory joyous
thanks but yeah it does lean into
someone else's troubles and difficulties
that was always what appeals to me about
it but I think the place we've learned
is the balance of that and it's still
being a heartwarming joyous experience
it cannot wait what are you filming next
I have no idea oh wow yeah enjoy the
vacation